okay ladies let's see what's under these
wigs
it's gonna be a hot mess are you ready
to show us
you ready stace let's do it
let's see
ah here it is freedom gotta let it gotta
let it out
oh feels good
shake it out steve take it out this is
the this is the real deal over here
no we got the second great patch same
one face
i thought i had more gray than you but
no it looks like you have more gray like
a skunk patch
i'm starting to look like nana a little
bit flooring loves my natural hair
the curls same with georgie but i'm
ready for a new
set of extensions when we were younger
we do each other's extensions
not the glue gun but the yeah the
i i can't remember we're getting old
these patches have to go sexy glam
that's right
we just have our own hair we used to be
down to our butts when we were pregnant
yeah
our hair was nice like like in our 20s
luscious and and now i feel like i have
no hair left
yeah so that's why we like the long
extensions
but first you gotta do the color and
then you gotta do the treatments and
then it's a long process
but i want that shine and that glam look
so i could feel
100.
all right ladies hear yourself oh that's
beautiful i don't know if it's okay with
you guys stacy and i
just have this um little ritual we do
that'll be out here yeah that's fine we
we pray and then we sage but yeah
okay so i just want to bless it
and you know this hair please lord god
love us honor us yeah and cherish us
with this hair
yes only good things come from this hair
we usually have a ritual we do with our
hair because we want to make sure that
the energy
from the new extensions are pure and
you know not holding on to any
negativity from whoever had it before us
we rebuke any evil energy
once we attach it to our head
[Music]
let it go let it go whatever negative
energy is
on that batch of hair we let it go all
right let's just change it a little bit
you